Il a parlé de choses extrêmement concrètes,
il a stigmatisé personne.
J'ai pas entendu de stigmatisation.
Mais attendez,
le fait que. Il faut qu'on leur supprime la SS, pourquoi ?
Mais en fait, qu'est-ce qui justifie ça ?
Mais le fait qu'on veut
renvoyer les gens au travail,
c'est. C'est social,
on n'est pas obligé de leur supprimer les.
C'est pas. C'est pas 1 mauvaise chose que de travailler,
c'est pas 1 chose négative. Supprimer les aides,
c'est à. Les aides à travailler, en fait.
Mais euh. Le RSA, c'est conditionné,
c'est conditionné. Pour
revenir au travail,
je parle de l'allocation de. De solidarité spécifique.
Vous avez 1 autre projet de société
que vous appelez 1 autre projet de société.
Euh. Répugnant.
Ouais, parce que on n'a
absolument pas stigmatisé qui que ce soit.
Alors supprimez la SS à les aides.
Mais écoutez, depuis le début,
à chaque fois qu'on parle de mesure concrète,
vous considérez.
Non mais c'est.
C'est la surprise. Répondez-moi, sur le fond, la.
La réalité, c'est que. Supprime la SS,
vous supprimez la SS. La solidarité à la source,
c'est le meilleur moyen
de faire bénéficier à des gens qui sont loin
justement des aides sociales,
de leur redonner des aides sociales.
Pourquoi
supprimer les aides au chômeur en fin d'endroit ?
Mais parce. Mais en fait, pourquoi ?
Je suis pas d'accord avec votre constat.
Non mais je ne suis pas d'accord avec ça.
Il a proposé de le supprimer,
je ne suis pas d'accord avec votre manière,
systématiquement.
De penser que sous prétexte que on incite les gens
à aller plus rapidement dans l'emploi,
on leur supprime absolument tous les droits.
En l'occurrence vous la supprimez,
mais non mais si, il l'a annoncé.